madame la présidente madame
l'ambassadrice mes chers collègues en
déposant cette proposition de résolution
nous manifestons notre volonté de
contribuer au règlement passifs
terriblement meurtrier
qui dure hélas depuis trop longtemps et
je salue d'ailleurs les propos de nos
collègues successifs qui m'ont précédés
à la tribune ce soir
parlementaire français nous sommes
viscéralement attachés aux valeurs qui
fondent le droit international et
permettre d'édifier une société des
nations
respectueuse du droit des peuples et
cette guerre lointaine passer sous
silence témoigne d'une situation
tellement préoccupante
nous défendons le principe
d'autodétermination des peuples et nous
condamnons fermement les agressions
meurtrières lancé par l'Azerbaïdjan
cet état qui n'a jamais respecté les
accords signés
en 94 et en 2020 et c'est bien lui qui a
déclenché en artsart la guerre des
quatre jours en 2016 la guerre des 44
jours en 2020 et encore les attaques
meurtrières des 13 et 14 septembre 2022
cette fois dirigé sur des villes et
villages d'Arménie
pète trompeuse nuit plus que guerre
ouverte dit-on
mais nous le savons la seule issue est
une pêche juste et durable dont les
protagonistes seront les acteurs elle
doit absolument se construire dans
l'acceptation de l'autre la culture
arménienne est l'une des plus anciennes
du monde et le haut Karaba l'un des
berceaux de l'humanité la société
azerbajanaise est fondée historiquement
sur le dialogue des cultures même si la
laïcité y est aujourd'hui en être recule
nous respectons l'identité de chaque
peuple de chaque minorité et
particulièrement celle des Arméniens
qui de par leur histoire ont eu à subir
des persécutions mais comment faire
prévaloir le droit face à des états qui
ne reconnaissent pas le droit et qui
détiennent de surcroît l'arme du gaz
face à la réal politique le jeu
d'influence des grands acteurs de la
région et une oligarchie qui s'est
approprié les richesses de l'Azerbaïdjan
nous ne sommes pas naïfs et s'il est
indéniable que l'influence de la Russie
pèsera encore longtemps sur la région du
Sud caucase la guerre en Ukraine et la
crise énergétique ont permis à la
zaribaïdjan de rouvrir les hostilités
menace gravement aujourd'hui la sécurité
des populations
de l'Arménie et de la tsar la question
du statut de cette petite république
auto proclamée et posée tout comme le
respect de la souveraineté territoriale
et de la dépendance de la République
d'Arménie le rock l'Europe doit donc
s'affirmer comme un médiateur et la
France plus encore
amis s'il en est de l'Arménie le devoir
d'agir en puissance garante de sa
souveraineté ce qu'elle sait d'ailleurs
est forcé de faire dans le cadre du
Groupe de Minsk il faut saluer en ce
sens l'initiative du Président de la
République
en octobre dernier à Prague t'avoir
réussi à réunir le président Alif le
Président le premier ministre pardon
pachinian est le président Michel le
déploiement d'une mission d'observation
de l'Union européenne du côté arménien
de la frontière internationale avec
l'Azerbaïdjan est une première étape
nous souhaitons que cette mission puisse
être prolongée ce qui ne nous dispense
pas aux côtés de l'Union européenne de
marquer notre plein détermination à
obtenir le rétablissement d'une paix
juste et durable et la sécurité pour les
peuples de cette région sous l'égide de
l'ONU
mais n'oublions pas que des sanctions
devront suivre
sanction contre les criminels et pas
seulement les auteurs des crimes sur les
théâtres d'opérations si la partie
tiendra à une enquête internationale et
indépendante les faits des sanctions
économiques et financières s'imposent
enfin nous appelons de nos vœux la
libération et le rapatriement immédiat
des prisonniers de guerre Arméniens mes
chers collègues
l'Assemblée nationale c'est toujours
tenu aux côtés de l'Arménie pour
exprimer sa solidarité et promouvoir une
solution diplomatique à ce conflit en
témoigne différentes résolutions adoptée
au fil des législatures et vous me
permettrez en ces instants
d'évoquer l'action de notre ancien
collègue mon ami François Rochebloine
qui a été rapporteur de la loi de 2001
autorisant la France à reconnaître le
génocide arménien 1915 cette fois encore
notre groupe démocrate est au
rendez-vous en votant cette résolution
je vous en remercie